nouvelle fois sur la sellette nos
confrères du canard enchaîné révèle ce
matin que certains banquiers nous font
payer trop cher semble-t-il les
découverts sommes-nous assez vigilants
sans doute pas les banques ont-elles
vraiment perçu indûment plusieurs
milliards de francs
nous répondrons nous essaierons de
répondre à ces questions dans quelques
instants
en attendant voici les autres titres du
journal de 20 heures
le gouvernement veut donner un coup
d'arrêt aux accidents au delà des
mesures d'urgence michel rocard rappelle
que la sécurité doit passer par une
prise de conscience collective
situation bloquée en pologne la fermeté
du pouvoir n'a pas démobilisé les
contestataires et surprise on apprend ce
soir que les syndicalistes officiel
brandissent la menace de la grève
générale
au burundi les massacres se poursuivre
la guerre entre les ethnies aurait très
près de 5000 morts pour la première fois
vous entendrez le témoignage des
réfugiés au rwanda sport 88 ou l'année
noire d'un champion jean françois
bernard l'une des coqueluches du
cyclisme français est écarté de la
sélection du championnat du monde
michel rocard persiste et signe
après le cri d'alarmé d'hier consacrée à
l'inconscience des chauffards le premier
ministre a confirmé aujourd'hui que le
gouvernement allait donner un coup
d'arrêt aux accidents la sécurité
routière est devenue un objectif
prioritaire a révélé le gouvernement il
y aura des contrôles techniques plus
rigoureux il y aura des mesures plus
dissuasives et il y aura aussi
résorption de plusieurs dizaines de
points noirs
le premier ministre veut faire oublier
les chiffres souvenez-vous plus de 9000
morts en 1987
plus de 170 mille accidents sur les
routes de france
il souhaite aussi gommer d'autres images
notamment celle des grands accidentés de
la route
michel rocard a souhaité les rencontrer
cet après midi leur détresse dépassé de
loin toutes les mises en garde
reportage de rémy roche de munich 22 ans
grave accident de vélomoteur comme à
plusieurs interventions chirurgicales
hospitalisé à garges depuis un mois et
demi alors je me sens bien mais je suis
pas là je peux pas écrire une légende
quoi quand même temps vous pensé rester
ici aucune idée j'ai soupesé tous
c'est un an plus âgés seront qu'est ce
qu'on vous a dit mon mari et elle n'a
pas dit quand on gère rester ils sont de
toutes origines de tous âges et la
moitié d'entre eux sont des accidentés
de la route
ils viennent de toute la france car au
delà des activités d'urgence c'est son
service de rééducation qui a fait la
réputation de l'hôpital poincaré
rééducation qui ici commence très tôt
parfois même alors que le malade est
encore sans connaissance démarrer vite
pour éviter les complications liées à
l'immobilisation le service dispose
d'une importante équipe kinésithérapeute
ergothérapeute orthophoniste mais aussi
psychologue car la rééducation c'est
souvent surtout pour ses grandes
handicap et la réadaptation à une vie
radicalement nouvelle
si c'est un malade qui a subi un
traumatisme crânien le malheureux il est
est souvent à peine réveillés à peine
conscient et donc il prend conscience
très progressivement lorsqu'ils arrivent
ici de ce ski est en vie il sait pas ce
qu est arrivé il est tout à fait
confluent désorienté 6 d'un traumatisme
médullaire qui n'a pas plu de trauma
crânien associés alors là il est tout à
fait conscient consciente de l'accident
tôt - mais pas conscients de du drame
qui arrive ce n'est que beaucoup plus
tard plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois
plus tard qu'il se rendra compte qu'il
n'a plus l'usagé de ses bras et de ses
jambes
réapprendre la vie c'est d'abord tenter
de re devenir progressivement mettre de
son environnement
dans les cas les plus graves comme ici
grâce à l'ordinateur qui fonctionne sur
fréquences vocales
c'est aussi bien sûr préparer sa
réinsertion sociale l'informatique à
laquelle sont initiés certains
tétraplégique offre l avantage d'un
accès physique simplifiée grâce au
clavier
là encore commencé tôt pendant
l'hospitalisation c'est gagner du temps
c'est surtout la possibilité de trouver
vite un nouvel objectif valorisant dans
une existence qui a été dramatiquement
bouleverser
après sa visite à l'hôpital
raymond-poincaré de garches le premier
ministre a dit une nouvelle fois toute
sa détermination dans la lutte contre
les accidents
michel rocard table d'abord sur une
prise de conscience collective
écoutez nous manquons de fraternité
routière et je voudrais continuer cette
notion dans la tête pour pouvoir dire
aux français ne mettaient pas en danger
la vie de vos enfants ne mettez pas en
danger la vie des enfants des autres
ne tuez pas par inconscience ne blesser
pas par imprudence la fraternité elle
vaut aussi entre les automobilistes ce
soit à mon avenir aujourd'hui c'est tout
de même le monde de la sauvagerie
il y a là un fléau social d'une gravité
est plus forte que le cancer équivalente
à celle de l'alcoolisme du tabagisme
c'est un fléau social qu'il faut
attaquer le gouvernement entend s'y
mettre j'ai demandé au garde des sceaux
d'étudier la possibilité que dans le cas
de délit contre la sécurité routière
les auteurs d'infractions puisse être
condamné à une peine de substitution qui
seraient quelques jours quelques
semaines quelques mois on ne sait de
services gratuits soit monsieur le
professeur pour venir compléter pour ce
qui concerne l'entretien ou les
déplacements des petits fauteuils mais
personnel qui vous sont manquants vous
avez insuffisances dans un hôpital comme
celui ci soit pour en rire les fonctions
de dire ce personne auprès d'handicapés
g voilà en dehors des mesures concrètes
michel rocard a annoncé que les
amnisties sur les contraventions
seraient réduites dans sept ans
catégorique il a également annoncé la
fin des passe droits pour faire annuler
les contraventions fin de citation la
révélation du jour signée par nos
confrères du canard enchaîné il arrive
que les banques fassent payer trop cher
les découverts mais oui nos confrères
s'appuie sur un arrêté de la cour de
cassation qui stipule que les banques ne
peuvent percevoir les intérêts sur les
découverts écoutez bien qu'à un taux
fixé à l'avancé ce par écrit apparemment
ça n'était pas toujours le cas alors ce
soir vous vous en doutez la chasse aux
agios arbitraire est lancé faut dire que
quand on fait les comptes
on s'aperçoit que plusieurs milliards de
francs ont été indûment perçues par les
banques
explications de maryse mano la bonne
nouvelle c'est pour les grands
dépensiers adeptes du découvert bancaire
ils ont payé trop d'agios et peuvent
récupérer cet argent au moins pour les
trois dernières années sans le canard
enchaîné il ne leur est pas su c'est le
12 avril dernier que la cour de
cassation a déclaré illégale la
perception d'agios tel qu'il est
pratiqué par les banques les taux
d'intérêt doit être indiquée par écrit
or dans le cas où il n'est pas indiqué
par écrit la cour de cassation a
justement décidé d'appliquer le taux de
base bancaire légal c'est d'ailleurs
l'un fait ni ce qui change ce n'est plus
le 15 à 18% auquel était axé les clients
actuellement
alors nous nous allons demander en effet
comme la cour de cassation
nous y encourage nous allons aider les
clients qui veulent récupérer des sommes
sur trois ans à faire une procédure tout
à fait légal et nous verrons ce qu'il en
est et ce qu'il en advient puisque les
tribunaux sont souverains mais rien ne
dit que les clients vont exiger le
remboursement car le retour de bâton est
possible la banque sera moins enclines à
accorder des découverts aux râleurs je
serais tombé
carrément
à partir du moment où il ya des ours et
la mafia puis deux volets benq n'ai
jamais rien on les perd dans ton temps
alors c'est pas la peine de lutter
contre ces vols a pas qu'on bâtit ses
clients car le remboursement des agios
pourrait atteindre 20 milliards de fonds
si tout le monde
entreprises et particuliers réclamer son
dû les banques comptent bien y échapper
arguant du fait que les jours pilier est
en principe accepter le seul élément
certain c'est qu'effectivement les
obligations d'information pesant sur les
banques ont été précisés et que les
banques se conformeront à ses
obligations
quant au passé il faut examiner les
situations individuelles ce que personne
ne peut faire en général pour le passé
c'est donc à chacun de tenter sa chance
mais pour l'avenir
rien n'empêche la banque de spécifier à
l'avancé et par écrit les mêmes tôt
qu'aujourd'hui
l'actualité c'est encore la rigueur d'un
chiffre le déficit du commerce extérieur
s'est sérieusement dégradée en juillet
88 3 4 milliards de francs contre 0 9
milliard en juin dernier soit quatre
fois plus qu'en juin 88 vous avez fait
les comptes
dégradation soudaine gérard leclerc
peut-on déjà avancé une première
explication m'a écoutée en tout cas
disons que le chiffre est mauvais qu'il
tombe au pire moment après février c'est
le plus gros difficile de l'année en
particulier pour les échanges de
produits industriels qui enregistre un
creux historique de plus de 4 milliards
le double du mois précédent les
entreprises françaises ont moins exporté
alors qu'elle continue à s'équiper en
machine étrangères notre déficit
extérieur se creusent aussi bien avec
l'europe qu'avec les autres pays
industriels alors ce mauvais chiffres
tombent au plus mal au moment où
l'allemagne annonce un excédent
commercial elle record de près de 50
milliards de francs pour le même mois de
juillet et comme un malheur n'arrive
jamais seul les autorités allemandes
doivent décider demain une hausse de
leurs taux d'intérêts qui rendra le
marque encore plus attractif ça ne fait
pas les affaires du franc déjà un peu
chahuté et il n'est pas impossible que
pierre bérégovoy souhaite à son tour
obligé d'augmenter prochainement les
taux en france alors qu'il souhaite vous
savez au contraire les baisser pour le
commerce extérieur jean marie rausch
veut croire un accident en juillet il
compte sur un freinage de la
consommation des ménages donc des
importations et sur davantage de ventes
d'airbus pour redresser la situation en
fin d'année voilà en tout cas un sérieux
rappel à l'ordre
la rigueur en matière de budget de prix
et de salaires
reste pour le gouvernement français un
impératif merci gérard autres chiffres
du jour qui concerne les salaires le
traitement des fonctionnaires sera
revalorisé d'un pour cent à compter du
1er septembre prochain
cette décision fait suite aux rencontres
du ministre de la fonction publique
michel durafour avec les organisations
syndicales à paris escroquerie sans
précédent autour des parcs m 25 employés
de la ville de paris sont soupçonnés
d'avoir détourné plusieurs tonnes j'ai
bien dit plusieurs tonnes de pièces de
monnaie alors de 1 franc à 10 francs le
préjudice serait de l'ordre de 10
millions de francs les employés
interpellés étaient aux premières loges
évidemment car il était chargé de
collecter l'argent des parcs m en quête
de pascal deschamps et anne ponsinet un
monceau que dis-je à montceau une
montagne de pièces de monnaie voilà ce
que les enquêteurs de la brigade
financière ont découvert hier dans la
cave d'un modeste pavillon de banlieue
le propriétaire employé au service de la
collecte des horodateurs confondait
allègrement expliquent plusieurs de ses
collègues les caisses de la ville de
paris avec son propre porte-monnaie
comment ont-ils pu détourner près de 10
millions de francs mystère pour la
mairie de paris
le système présentait pourtant toutes
les garanties en principe il ya un
système de sécurité double sécurité avec
un système de pelé il faut à la fois que
l'appareil soit intégré à leurs
auditeurs et que leur système de qu'elle
fonctionne donc théoriquement
théoriquement il ne peut pas y avoir de
dalea malheureusement l'expérience
prouve qu'il y en a eu un
ça prouve qu'il ya une astuce qui a été
découverte par ceux qui se sont mal
conduit c'est le train de vie d'un de
ses employés voiture coûteuse bateaux
etc qui a mis la puce à l'oreille des
enquêteurs il contrastait singulièrement
avec son salaire mensuel
4624 en 28 le plus difficile devait sans
doute être de payer les achats en menue
monnaie
mais depuis 1986 on n'est plus obligé
d'acquitter par chèque les sommes
supérieures à 10 mille francs 48 heures
après la proclamation du couvre-feu la
pologne s'installe dans la grève mais
les grévistes s'attendent à une
intervention prochaine de la milice et
de la police une première intervention a
eu lieu d'ailleurs hier soir dans une
mine de cils et
si au sud ouest de la pologne pour
l'heure la fermeté du gouvernement n'a
donc donné aucun résultat et pour la
première fois depuis bien longtemps
moscou avoue sa préoccupation
dernière information étonnante qui est
tombé d'ailleurs en fin d'après midi
il semble il faut encore parler au
conditionnel que des syndicalistes
officiel brandies désormais la menace
d'une grève générale
jacques merlino après avoir bouclé les
usines en grève la pologne aujourd'hui à
boucler l'information expulsions de
journalistes étrangers contrôlent des
reportages les seules images dont nous
disposons ce soir sont les images
officielles de la télévision polonaise
elles indiquent une reprise du travail
en certains lieux en fait mais aucune
caméra n'y était cette reprise partielle
est consécutive à une série
d'interventions brutales la police au
cours de la nuit dernière les forces de
l'ordre après de violents affrontements
ont chassé les grévistes qui occupaient
leurs établissements parallèlement de
nouvelles arrestations étaient effectués
il y aurait actuellement une centaine de
personnes retenues dans les locaux de la
police pression musclée du pouvoir mais
aussi tentative de séduction
le bureau politique du parti communiste
polonais dans un communiqué a simplement
mis l'accent sur la nécessité
d'instaurer un véritable processus
d'entente nationale et s'est gardé de
toute critique violente envers les
grévistes
enfin ce soir nous apprenions que les
représentants des syndicats officiels il
centaine d'entreprises menacé d'appeler
à la grève générale
une information difficile à évaluer dans
le contexte actuel l'image symbole
demain à genève après huit ans de guerre
l'iran et l'irak
que vont s'asseoir à la même table de
négociation monsieur perez de cuellar le
secrétaire général des nations unies
estiment que les discussions seront
longues et souvent difficile quelques
jours après la mise en place du
cessez-le-feu le plus dur sera sans
doute la désignation d'un organe
impartiale chargée d'enquêter sur la
responsabilité du conflit à genève pour
antenne 2 le commentaire de patrice irin
négociations placées sous le signe du
secret et de la plus grande méfiance
arrivé en premier des iraniens avec
essentiellement des juristes des
techniciens et des arpenteurs monsieur
velayati ministre des affaires
étrangères doit s'installer dans cette
résidence et ne plus en sortir jusqu'à
la réunion de demain matin avec monsieur
perret d'equalia
il n'aura donc pas l'occasion de croiser
l irakien tarek aziz qui va s'enfermer à
son tour dans sa mission
ici à l'onu même atmosphère feutrée très
peu de mesures de sécurité l'endroit se
veut ouvert et son secrétaire général
optimiste il n'est pas très inquiet des
dernières violation de cessez le feu
il prévoit en revanche des négociations
dures et peut-être très longue avec
comme principal point litigieux
le problème de la frontière sur le
fleuve chatt el arab
mais en attendant pour commencer les
deux délégations devront s'entendre sur
un calendrier
ce qui est loin d'être acquis toujours
des remous en birmanie le président wang
gang s'est prononcé tout à l'heure en
faveur d'un référendum pour ou contre le
maintien du parti unique au pouvoir dès
hier soir la loi martiale avait été
levée à rangoon la capitale
le président avait pris cette décision
alors que deux cent mille personnes
défilent et précisément dans les rues de
la capitale
la manifestation s'est déroulée sans
incident majeur hier par contre la
veille à quelques kilomètres seulement
de la frontière thaïlandaise
les forces de l'ordre avaient ouvert le
feu bilan 31 morts peut être plus et
plus de 80 blessés la levée de la loi
martiale apparaît aujourd'hui comme une
concession aux manifestants mais cette
mesure est aussi un constat d'échec du
gouvernement qui n'a pas su désamorcer
la révolte populaire
bernard benaïem ils étaient ce matin
plus d'un million de personnes à rome
un million de personnes qui réclamaient
le retour à la démocratie de cette
ancienne colonie britannique
quelques heures plus tôt il avait appris
par un communiqué la levée de la loi
martiale
une première victoire qui les avaient
rassemblés dans la rue pour la plus
grande manifestation qu'ait jamais connu
la birmanie un peu plus tard nouveau
coup de théâtre le numéro un birman
monsieur manque propose un référendum
pour abolir le système de parti unique
et ne s'arrête pas là
si mon idée rejetée dit il je
démissionne ainsi que les treize autres
membres du comité exécutif du parti
la réponse à cet ultimatum pour la
connaîtra le 12 septembre prochain
ce jour là le parti socialiste guerman
se réunit en session extraordinaire pour
prendre une décision à ce sujet et d'ici
là il ya tout lieu de pouvoir que la
pression de la rue se renforcera pour
amener le parti unique à se soumettre
pour la première fois au verdict des
urnes et situation toujours très tendue
en afrique au burundi ce petit pays de
28 mille kilomètres carrés coincé entre
le rwanda la tanzanie et le zaïre doit
faire face depuis quelques semaines à
des rivalités ethniques qui oppose deux
tutsi actuellement au pouvoir hutu qui
sont majoritaires dans la population
le premier bilan des massacres fait état
d'au moins 5000 morts près de 40000
burundais se sont réfugiés au rwanda
les sommes que vous allez voir c'est
d'ailleurs la toute première fois que
nous recevons des images autour du
conflit ont fui leur pays par crainte de
représailles
la plupart sont blessés traumatisés
jean-marc il use
voici les premières images des quarante
mille réfugiés hutus au rwanda c'est
pour échapper au massacre de l'art et
nient qu'ils ont franchi la frontière de
leur pays
le burundi
et avec eux nous parviennent les
premiers témoignages directs
après trois semaines de sanglants
affrontements tribaux témoignages
concordants du moins de ce côté ci de la
frontière pour mettre en cause l'armée
burundaise une armée à majorité tutsi
les ennemis héréditaires des audio
beaucoup de blessés à la machette chez
ceux qui ont pu fuir d'autres tombés
sous les balles auraient été enterrés
sur place bien différente la version du
gouvernement burundais qui affirme que
l'armée a dû intervenir après de
véritables attaque de guérillas lancé
selon lui contrôler tout l'est par des
exilés ou tout selon le gouvernement
burundais
ces rebelles je cite voulait ainsi vengé
les massacre de 72 massacres qui avaient
fait au moins cent mille victimes chez
les hutus à l'époque ces chiffres
n'avaient guère ému la communauté
internationale aujourd'hui le
gouvernement burundais parle de 5000
morts sans qu'il soit encore possible
d'établir de manière indépendante les
responsabilités et la véritable
complique du drame les télégrammes
d'actualité comme chaque soir avec un
nouveau style ensuite nous évoquons la
rentrée sociale et nous parlerons
également de rentrée politique
la ville de koundouz en afghanistan
prise par les rebelles il ya une dizaine
de jours a été réinvesti par l'armée
régulière après des combats très
meurtriers
par ailleurs un convoi transportant des
armes dans la province de laghman a été
interceptée dix résistants étaient des
tués au cours de l'accrochage
françois mitterrand devant le 11e
congrès international des archives c'est
la mémoire du monde que vous préserver
et que vous mettez en valeur a dit le
président aucun sens archiviste venus de
plus de 100 pays il ajoute j'ai voulu
que les archives soit traitée comme une
dimension essentielle de la vie
nationale
au lendemain de la mort du souverain
gadier claude marti tué par deux
malfaiteurs à perpignan sa veuve est
entouré de la solidarité morale et
financière de l'ensemble de la police un
hommage national sera rendu au défunt
le policier sera promu un grade
supérieur à titre posthume
la candidature officieuse de bernard
tapie à la reprise de la société donnait
déclarer en faillite a été accueillie
avec soulagement en belgique où l'on
redoutait la disparition d'une des plus
célèbres marques de raquette plusieurs
boucles étrangers ont témoigné leur
intérêt pour donner parmi eux un groupe
de hong kong
mais bernard tapie pourrait prendre ses
concurrents de vitesse estime-t-on à
bruxelles la politique en bref haroun
tazieff que l'on ne présente plus
anciens ministres socialistes du
gouvernement fabius sera soutenue par le
maire rpr de grenoble alain carignon
lors des prochaines élections cantonales
dans l'isère on l'a appris tout à
l'heure à paris après avoir reçu un
satisfecit de françois mitterrand le
chef de l'état michel rocard s'est
envolé ce soir pour la nouvelle
calédonie sur place je vous rappelle que
jacques lafleur
le leader du rpcr a demandé à la
population d' écouter attentivement le
premier ministre à noter encore que cet
après midi à paris le bureau politique
de l'udf a commenté l'accord sur
l'avenir de la nouvelle calédonie je
vous propose d'écouter les propos du
porte parole de l'udf monsieur
lamassoure
le bureau politique de l'udf se réjouit
qu'un accord soit intervenu entre les
représentants des communautés à propos
du statut futur de la nouvelle calédonie
l'udf est prête à participer aux
délibérations législatives en vue de la
mise en oeuvre de cet accord
en revanche elle s'interroge sur
l'opportunité d'un référendum qui en
raison de la multiplication des
élections risquent de connaître un
faible taux de participation
henri krasucki l'annoncé ce matin au
cours d'une conférence de presse la
rentrée sociale de la cgt sera très
combative il faut qu'elle ait tous
azimuts a dit en substance le secrétaire
général de la cgt en précisant que
l'action ne se programme pas comme une
opération d'état-major à propos des
grèves en pologne henri krasucki affirmé
que la cgt était solidaire des
travailleurs polonais affiliés au
syndicat officiel précision importante
à noter également un couplet sur
l'europe qui a surpris plus d'un
observateur
contrairement à edmond maire et andré
bergeron la cgt pense que l'europe est
un danger pour les travailleurs
il est encore temps mais il est plus
juste de temps
de rendre impossible ce qui est
inacceptable c'est faisable
dès lors que les les travailleurs en
premier et l'opinion saisissent
l'étendue de la supercherie et la
gravité des dégâts
cette europe qu'on nous a présentés
souriante et c'est la perte de
l'indépendance nationale de la france et
c'est le sacrifice des intérêts des
travailleurs français comme ceux des
pays d autres pays concernés on nous dit
que ce serait inévitable rien et ils les
mutins
un nouveau patron pour la sncf comme
prévu c'est jacques fournier un proche
de françois mitterrand ancien secrétaire
général du gouvernement est également
auteur d'un célèbre traité du social qui
prend la tête de l'entreprise jacques
fournier va diriger deux cent treize
mille cheminots des hommes que l'on dit
plus ou moins déstabilisés par la grande
grève de décembre 86 et surtout par les
accidents ferroviaires de cet été
reportage françoise joly et christophe
martel inquiétudes malaise crise de
confiance c'est le trouble à la sncf
après les longues semaines de grèves de
l'hiver 86 les accidents de cet été
l'entreprise et ses 213 8 salariés sont
encore sous le choc
c'est le cas la préparation 137 yves ans
et jusqu'à 28 ans entré à la sncf en
1977 il a passé tous les examens pour
être conducteur mais a dû attendre deux
ans et demi avant d'avoir un poste
correspondant à sa qualification pour
les jeunes faire carrière à la sncf
devient plus difficile est à l'image de
ses collègues
yvan expriment aujourd'hui une grande
lassitude c'est tout un ensemble de
choses
il ya un problème de communication il ya
un problème de condition de travail à un
problème de salaires c'est tout un c'est
tout un ensemble de choses qui font que
certaines paires certaine période on
arrive à être démotivés
la période des vacances particulièrement
pénible on travaille beaucoup plus
beaucoup de plus qu'en temps normal
objet de toutes les controverses le
contrat de plan signé par l'état et la
sncf en avril 85
celui ci prévoit l'équilibré financier
pour 1989
c'est à cette seule condition que les
pouvoirs publics acceptent de maintenir
leur aide
mais cet assainissement de l'entreprise
passe par des suppressions d'emplois
41000 depuis quatre ans beaucoup de
cheminots juge l'évolution trop rapide
si vous faites et j'ai de vrais plus
nous entendre entende et les gens qui
sont sur le talent et sait se faire
entendre se faire comprendre
c'est à tous les échelons que les
cheminots souligner l'absence de
dialogue
a la sncf la courroie de transmission
entre le pdg les hommes du terrain passe
par de nombreux relais et c'est là toute
la difficulté de l'entreprise d'une part
de par sa taille au point de vue nombre
de d'employés mais aussi de par sa
dimension géographique
c'est une grande maison sncf et c'est
difficile à se faire comprendre
paradoxalement la tâche la plus délicate
qui attend le nouveau patron de la sncf
n'est plus d'assainir les comptes mais
bien de vaincre
les des cheminots en sport je vous
rappelle qu en football l'équipe de
france accueille ce soir la
tchécoslovaquie c'est au parc des
princes à partir de 20h30 et c'est aussi
un match amical mais en toile de fond il
ya quand même la qualification pour le
mondial 90 résultats et commentaires
dans le dernier journal d'antenne 2 ce
soir aux alentours de 23 heures
cyclisme 88 décidément mauvaise saison
et année noire pour jean françois
bernard bernard ne défendra pas les
couleurs françaises dans les
championnats du monde c'est officiel son
éviction n'est pas en soi une très très
grande surprise
francis maroteaux jean françois bernard
qui essuie un refus pour le championnat
du monde de rooney en belgique dur mais
pas vraiment étonnant d'ailleurs le
leader des toshiba se confient à alain
vernon il ya quelques jours à ce propos
je pense que dans quinze jours ce sera
trop juste pour chanter la demande pour
les nations je pense que ça sera bon
mais en fait tout se décide qui hier à
plouay à l'occasion du grand prix
ils sont 150 au départ mais surtout ils
sont 18 pour 12 places
parmi eux donc jean françois bernard qui
anime le début de course mais s'arrête
après 12 tours le championnat du monde
c'est fini
déception bien sûr mais là encore est ce
qu'on en demande pas trop et trop vite à
jeff comme il est surnommé j'ai tout de
suite été amené
ait amené près aux dés que je suis passé
professionnel deux mois après en
terminant 5e du tour de l'avenir et je
crois que là tout de suite les gens ont
beaucoup misé sur moi peut-être plus
qu'il ne fallait à ce moment là c'est à
dire que j'ai été monté très haut très
vite et je crois qu'il fera peut-être
attendre deux trois ans et peut-être que
je suis un coureur plus lent qu'on le
pensait autre absent de marque
eric boyer le meilleur français du tour
88 n'ira pas en belgique et là c'est
vraiment la surprise mais en fait en
fait eric boyer discret hier à plouay
blessés sur chute au tour des pays bas
se remet peut-être plus difficilement
que prévu de son excellent tour de
france tissé si on va pas revoir un
certain laurent fignon pourquoi pas
charly mottet attendant c'est dans
quelques jours
voile avant de rendre l'antenne nous
allons san de saluer l'exploit d'un
autre grand sportif il s'appelle
stéphane perron et il vient d'atteindre
c'est un authentique exploit le voilà le
pôle nord magnétique en planche à voile
la précision est importante
stéphane perron est arrivé à traction
thaïlande hier soir à 22h25 le
véliplanchiste a bénéficié de vents
favorables dans les dernières heures il
n'était en effet attendu que dans la
journée de demain a ajouté son
porte-parole stéphane peyron avait
quitté resolute bay dans l'antarctique
canadien le 30 juillet dernier
sacré exploit et bravo les pronostics de
pierrette brès pour le quarté de demain
c'est à vincennes dans le prix de sa
voix il y a quinze partants voici les
favoris de pire est il faut jouer
impérativement le 12 le 13 le 15 le 6 le
dise le 7 le 2 et le 8
je récapitule brièvement le 12 le 13 le
15 le 6 le dise le 7 le 2 et le 8
résultats et rapports dans le journal de
20 heures demain après le journal vous
retrouverez laurent cabrol comme tous
les soirs pour les prévisions météo
prochain rendez-vous d'information vers
23h35
le tout dernier journal il sera présenté
par aubry et de l'air demain 6h45
n'oubliez pas télématin et à 13h le
journal de la mi journée avec en ce
moment hervé claude je me retrouve
demain à 20 heures merci de votre
fidélité
bonsoir
oh